oui bonjour une nouvelle semaine de sa
aux cadis donc qui débute avec
jean-philippe ni l'or bonjour bonjour et
bonjour à tous ceux qui nous écoutent
vous êtes député élu dans la 4e
circonscription celle dite du sud 1-2
notre île vous êtes à l'assemblée
nationale membre de la commission des
affaires sociales vous êtes également
conseiller territorial à l'assemblée de
martinique
et puis aussi coprésident avec marcellin
nadeau du parti politique pays à parti
qui a été officialisée publiquement
présenté publiquement en février dernier
et là vous avez donc effectuer votre
rentrée politique 2019-2020 vendredi
dernier à ducos jean philippe miller
avec en perspective bien sûr les
élections municipales qui sont dans dans
cinq mois
alors quels enjeux revêt ce rendez-vous
des municipales pour un tout jeune parti
comme le vôtre pour le pays a déjà point
tout jeune parti comme le nôtre la
rentrée politique la première rentrée
politique c'est un moment solennel c'est
un moment très important et je veux dire
que nous avons abordé avec beaucoup
d'humilité mais beaucoup d'espérance et
la participation populaire nous l'a bien
rendu
il faut dire qu'il y avait beaucoup de
monde il y avait beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
mais aussi beaucoup de dignité et nous
avons voulu imprimer et c'est ce que
nous voulons en fait dans le paysage
politique martiniquais imprimer une
autre manière de faire de la politique
une manière beaucoup plus apaisé on ne
considère pas que un adversaire
politique c'est un ennemi ou on n'est
pas dans le canton n'est pas dans ledit
quatre sièges on essaye de d'illustrer
concrètement les principes de co
construction
l'idée qu'il n'ya pas un homme
providentiel qui va tout régler pour la
martinique mais c'est que c'est ensemble
que nous pourrons aborder sereinement et
efficacement la situation difficile de
notre pays
enfin tous ces principes ce socle de
valeurs que nous avons mises en avant
je crois que
les retours du public non seulement de
ceux qui étaient très nombreux
un présent mais même de ceux qui
n'étaient pas présents sont très
positives et nous encouragent
j'en fais depuis lors effectivement il y
avait du monde ça peut être des
sympathisants partie non mais voyez ce
que j'ai à parce que en février là quand
vous avez lancé donc pays à vous
revendiquez 140 adhérents
quelques mois après est-ce que vous avez
augmenté gonfler vos et bien ses
adhérents c'était au premier jour
dimanche soir c'était déjà à porter de
beaucoup d'espoir il ya beaucoup de
partis politiques qui à ce jour que des
décennies d'existence qui n'ont pas 140
adhérents donc 141 premier jour c'était
déjà beaucoup
ce que je peux dire c'est que ça ne ça
n'arrête pas et nous avons sans faire
une campagne active pour solliciter les
adhésions
nous avons un flot continu de demandes
d'adhésion si bien en martinique en
dehors de la martinique
et ça c'est un phénomène qu'il faut
qu'il faut enlever nos compatriotes qui
vivent à travers le monde font la
démarche se rapproche de nous prennent
leur adhésion et et je veux dire ce qui
est le plus important en tout cas ce qui
porte le plus d'espoir pour nous c'est
que beaucoup de jeunes martiniquais
viennent à dire et de même à pia et
parfois même ce sont les enfants qui
emmènent leurs parents ap à jeudi que
demander de plus dans une situation un
contexte où la politique devient un
domaine très décriée alors je vous
demandais les municipales alors à quoi
elles vont servir pour pays à bon alors
on a bien compris vous dit qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde bon c'est pas pour
vous comptez pas dire ça mais voilà
est-ce que c'est bien nous cassons verra
bien on verra
c'est aussi l'occasion de voir quelle
force vous avez sur l'ensemble
finalement du territoire peut-être même
un galop d'essai pour les territoriales
de 2021 les six pales les municipales
sont un événement majeur tout simplement
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une
collectivité territoriale unique en
martinique et les municipalités doivent
souvent constitué en quelque sorte
3 contre-pouvoir par rapport à cette
collectivité unique donc il faut à la
tête de ces collectivités municipales
des personnes compétentes des personnes
formées des personnes dynamiques des
personnes qui maîtrisent un certain
nombre de techniques mais aussi des
personnes qui sont animés de valeurs qui
sont vertueuses qui sont saines pour la
martinique notamment le respect de
l'environnement le développement
économique mais le développement
économique qui doit être maîtrisé
l'aide aux porteurs de projets le
développement culturel éducationnel le
secteur associatif qui doit être une
priorité dans toutes les communes de
martinique
nous allons soutenir les candidats qui
partagent ses valeurs qui partagent
cette vision de leur commune et de la
martinique
alors vous allez soutenir soutenir des
candidats dites vous ça veut dire que
pays à ne sera pas en tant que tel
partout présent peu ou prou dans chacune
des communes
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
présenter non on va pas une candidate ou
un candidat labellisés pour ainsi dire
pays alors dans les 34 communes deux
choses non dans les 34 communes non ce
n'est pas souhaitable et ce n'est pas
aller vers l'efficacité nous nous
souhaitons nous donner de véritables
chances de remporter des scrutins dans
les communes donc vous ne connaissez un
petit peu même si on est jeune l'idée
c'est de ne pas se disperser de ce coup
de concentrer nos forces sur un certain
nombre de communes avec de vraies
perspectives de victoire pour ces
communes mais pour la martinique
quelques pas et puis d'autre part nous
n'allons pas chercher à faire du chiffre
systématiquement les municipales c'est
suffisamment important là où il ya des
équipes avec une dynamique locale parce
que la dynamique doit être localisée et
ne parle pas du territoire si on
considère que c'est un parti politique
qui va nommer quelqu'un qui va pas a
chuté quelqu'un et qui va imposer
quelqu'un dans une commune de martinique
on connaît mal la réalité sociopolitique
de la martinique donc nous sommes très
clairs là dessus
là où il y à des dynamiques
territoriales et où on fait appel au
soutien à l'investiture de pays à nous
avons une commission d'investiture qui
examine les dossiers les situations et
qui prend des décisions
enfin qu'il fait des propositions au
comité directeur de pays à qui valide ou
pas alors vous concernant
personnellement il ya un changement
c'est que vous avez peut-être que vous
le confirme et là je pense vous ne serez
pas candidat vous même pour les
prochaines municipales à saint plus je
ne sais pas je ne serai pas tête de
liste aux prochaines municipales ne
serait pas candidat tête de liste
récession vous voulez qu'il faut
rappeler que l'élection municipale c'est
une élection de liste est certes la tête
de liste est très importante et doit
pouvoir incarner quelque part une
dynamique mais il faut pas oublier que
et c'est dans notre adn aussi de pays on
ne valorise pas une personne un homme il
faut sortir de cette manière en caïques
de faire la politique
mais valoriser une équipe avec un projet
et une dynamique
je sais que c'est difficile à imposer
quelque part mais nous y arriverons
petit à petit la preuve je dire
lorsqu'on regarde pays on a créé en
partie sur la base de la coprésidence
beaucoup ont dit ça par kébé dans six
mois c'est mundaka décapiter la guérilla
est divorcée etc
les choses se passent très bien et cette
expérience le co présidence mais c'est
une expérience qui est positive utile
qui pourrait être utilisé dans d'autres
collectivités ailleurs mais l'idée même
de ne pas tout remettre dans les maîtres
d'une personne de ne pas avoir un chef
un lider maximo qui décide de tout et
puis que les autres soient uniquement
des exécutants c'est une idée qui a de
l'avenir et je crois que dans le
contexte martiniquais d'aujourd'hui
c'est une idée qui va s'imposer petit à
petit marcellin nadeau le coprésident
donc deux pays a lui en revanche ne
bombardent pas de surprise il est
candidat au prix cher évidemment il est
maire sortant il a annoncé nous allons
le soutenir
je crois que la candidature de marcelin
nadeau est normal donne beaucoup
communes de martinique je parle
objectivement franchement sincèrement
j'entends des gens qui me disent mais
ces deux mères comme ça qu'on aurait qu
on aurait besoin nous dans notre commune
c'est à dire que beaucoup de
martiniquais de grandes communes parce
qu'il faut pas oublier que pêcheur c'est
une petite commune en nombre d'habitants
mais c'est une grande commune au niveau
de la gestion municipale au niveau des
expériences qui sont menées au niveau de
la démocratie participative et quelque
part c'est
la gestion du prêcheur par manceau un
ado qui va donner le la aux autres
collectivités puisqu'il l'a déjà cette
expérience municipale
donc il va participer aussi à
l'élaboration des projets avec tous les
autres candidats que nous allons
soutenir
est-ce que vous d'ores et déjà vous
préparez des alliances alors on nous
disait ce sera un galop d'essai les
municipales mais notamment pour les
territoriales on sait que bon ça se joue
comme ça évidemment là aussi c'est un
scrutin de liste et pays à bon pourra
pas faire toutes les élections tout seul
à chaque fois que vous avez d'autres
partis voyez ce que vous est déjà en
train de constituer j'entends bien mais
il ya de par ses principes
les principes qui ont érigé pays a payé
n'a pas la vocation à et vouloir
s'imposer dominé tout le monde au
contraire nous avons ouvert dès le
départ la porte à tous ceux qui
voulaient travailler pour l'élaboration
d'un projet sérieux stables garantissant
la démocratie et le développement de la
martinique dont nous sommes ouverts
jeudi dans les communes ce sont des
dynamiques locales qui vont porter les
candidats à la victoire de quelques
camps qu'ils soient d'ailleurs est dense
et dynamique locale il ya des accords il
ya les gens de droite des gens de gauche
qui travaillent dans les mêmes équipes
aient entonné parfois surpris de voir
certains positionnements
heureusement qu'on n'est pas
complètement assujettis aux décisions
qui viennent d'en haut des partis
politiques est l'exemple le plus le plus
intéressant à mon avis c'est celui du
saint-esprit où nous dit-on sur le
terrain il ya des militants et de pays à
qui mène campagne à côté d'un militant
du mime
alors que au sommet on ne donne pas
l'exemple
voyez que les militants sont tout à fait
capables de donner l'exemple du
rassemblement de l'unité pour des idées
parce que concrètement au niveau
municipal
ce ne sont pas les mêmes et cher ce pour
ça s'agissant de la 7ème c'est le même
constat
il faudra s'unir il faudra s'ouvrir il
faudra s'allier mais saliès ou des bases
objectives et surtout
un projet sur une méthode et sur une
conception de la politique ce sont ces
sur ces principes là que nous serons
intransigeants
il s'agira pas de faire des alliances
contre nature et des alliances entre des
gens qui n'ont pas la même vision la
même conception de la politique
alors jean philippe on va conclure le
temps est court malheureusement je
voulais évoquer la dissolution du minon
s'oriente vers une dissolution du mime
qui sera prononcée par par la justice
bon tout ça est derrière vous vous ça
est derrière moi je ne jouais pas de de
ce qui se passe de négatif au sein de
mon ancien parti je serais mal placé
pour le faire
je déplore simplement qu' on en soit
arrivé là
tout simplement par entêtement des uns
des autres
voilà merci jean philippe miller d'avoir
répondu à nos questions dans sa ou qu'a
dit ce matin bonne journée merci
beaucoup
bonne journée à vous
[Musique]